opfern wir aus angst vor dem virus all
das was unser menschliches leben
ausmacht begrüße sehr herzlich thea dorn
schriftstellerin und philosophin ja das
ist ja so eine art möglicherweise von
einem selbstmord des eigenen lebens aus
angst vor dem tod
das ist wahrscheinlich die große
menschliche tragödie die wir gerade
erleben dass zumal für menschen die
nicht an ein besseres jenseits glauben
ist der tod die größte angst die wir
kennen
der tod ist das schlimmste was uns
passieren kann was unseren liebsten
zustoßen kann und das paradox entsteht
wenn wir aus dieser angst vor dem tod
die völlig berechtigt ist uns alles
verbieten was zum leben gehört weil es
eben gefährdend oder gefährlich sein
kann
wir werden zum thema tod gleich noch
intensiv kommen
jetzt haben wir doch im augenblick eine
phase mit der diskussion um öffnungen
wir haben eine diskussion um
schnelltests wir haben eine diskussion
darüber dass die kinder wieder in die
schule können die große hoffnung wie die
kanzlerin gesagt hat am ende des tunnels
das ist die impfung also das scheint
sich alles doch wieder zum guten zu
entwickeln
sie kritisieren trotzdem diese maßnahmen
und sagen das ist dem menschlichen leben
nicht angemessen ich bin nicht in erster
linie eine maßnahmen kritisiere rinn und
ich bin schon gar keine politikberaterin
ich bin schriftstellerin und als
schriftstellerin erlebe ich seit einem
jahr was in dem land in der gesellschaft
bei den menschen und aber natürlich auch
in der politik los ist und ich habe die
beobachtung gemacht dass es teilweise
kein ausreichendes verständnis glaube
ich gibt für die tragische situation in
der wir stecken
die menschen sind nach einem jahr
einfach so frustriert auch teilweise so
wütend trotzdem muss man sagen ist da
nicht ratio der verstand sie sind
philosophin also diese nüchterne
herangehen das richtige gewesen in den
letzten monaten oder sogar in einem
dreiviertel jahr wenn das überblicken wo
man immer wieder gesagt hat moment das
passt uns jetzt nicht aber wir müssen
das tun weil sonst ist das virus überall
und wir haben tote zu beklagen in einem
unverhältnismäßigen größenordnung
dazu muss man zum einen sagen sind wir
uns ganz sicher dass wir wirklich zu
jedem zeitpunkt vernünftig gehandelt
haben der politik hat sich sehr früh für
einen bestimmten weg entschieden und hat
dem dann
mit dieser aus meiner sicht für
demokratien heiklen vokabel der
alternativlosigkeit versehen und wenn
man die immensen diskussionen die es
auch innerhalb einer wissenschaftsszene
gab war es ja nun durchaus nicht so dass
man sagt das ist wirklich ganz klar dass
das vernünftigerweise der einzige weg
ist man kann eben so sagen ich habe mit
vielen menschen aus dem medizinischen
bereich gesprochen die sagen naja die
gesundheitskosten wenn wir jetzt bei
diesem segment bleiben sind auch immens
also wir können noch gar nicht richtig
überblicken was die pandemie
bekämpfungsmaßnahmen alles für andere
gesundheitliche schäden zeitigen werden
deshalb halte ich es für gefährlich zu
sagen hier steht ganz klar hier ist nur
die ratio und da sind irrational
außerdem bestehen wir doch als menschen
aus beidem
und das ist mein dringendes bedürfnis zu
sagen da muss es doch einen raum für
geben wir sind doch keine roboter den
man sagen kann ich programmiere euch
jetzt mal auf maximale risikovermeidung
und wehe ihr habt die menschlichen
spontan impulse ihr seht euch nach
freiheit ihr seht euch da noch danach
endlich mal wieder mit weiß ich nicht
acht leuten zu abend zu essen ihr seht
euch danach ins fußballstadion zu gehen
in die oper zu gehen
da kann man doch nicht immer nur sagen
jetzt seid ihr mal vernünftig dennoch
wenn ich sage ich umarme jemanden und
ich weiß nicht ob ich einen infekt vom
virus habe oder sie den haben und ich
mache es trotzdem
dann ist das gefühlsmäßig
nachvollziehbar je nach temperament aber
das ist sehr sehr unvernünftig da muss
ich doch sagen da muss der verstand erst
mal einsetzen und sagen das darf ich
jetzt nicht machen
sonst hätten wir doch ein ganz anderes
dramatisches infektionsgeschehen in den
letzten monaten erlebt werden die
menschen so miteinander umgegangen wären
wie vorher stimme ihnen völlig zu und
gleichzeitig muss man den satz sagen
dürfen und ich verstehe wie sehr du
darunter leidet und da sind mir die
sätze auch zu dem sich unsere
bundeskanzlerin durchgerungen hat wenn
sie mal so einen freuten jahren mir
bricht das herz umsatz kann man auch
schon anders sagen ganz ehrlich ich
glaube angela merkel diesen satz nie so
richtig geglaubt sondern das war eine
ganz klare
anforderungen an eine maximale risiko
vermeidungsstrategie sie können das
vernünftig aber ein verständnis zu
entwickeln
natürlich weiß ich dass politiker in
einer säkularen offenen gesellschaft
nicht primär fürs seelenheil der
bevölkerung zuständig sind dazu eben
leben wir in einem säkularen staat aber
ich habe schon den eindruck diese
gereiztheit die ich dann teilweise
höhere das sind dann so lockdown
weicheier und jetzt haltet euch endlich
mal dran das ist mir der falsche ton in
dieser pandemie die eben aus meiner
sicht nicht wiederholen sich dadurch
auszeichnet dass es eine tragische
situation ist in dem moment in dem ich
in der einen hinsicht was richtiges
mache wie gehe ich in anderer hinsicht
ja ich sage es ein unrecht an etwas und
menschen also das war für mich das
größte unrecht und deshalb der anlass
für dieses buch das größte unrecht war
für mich menschen zu einem einsamen tod
zu verdammen
da geht in mir wirklich ein antigone
artiger zorn los und wenn man dann wenn
ich dann nicht erleben dass politiker
sich auch hinstellen und erklären dass
sie ganz klar wissen das ist ein unrecht
dass wir begehen und mir erklären warum
sie das begehen müssen
das ist ja das kennzeichen der
tragischen sind das dumme ist nur der
virus verhält sich nicht an these
antithese synthese wenn wir das
philosophisch dialektisch mal sehen
bedeutet dass der virus dem ist das
völlig egal ob sie sagen wir machen
jetzt ein kompromiss wenn wir diesen
kompromiss machen dann freut sich der
virus weil er hat einen neuen wirt
dürfen wir das zulassen ist nicht groß
sich freuen kann ehrlich gesagt also mir
geht es ja ich rede ja auch nicht mit
dem virus weniger leben das virus will
leben ja wohl dafür ist es programmiert
worden von der natur und die menschheit
will auch überleben in gewisser weise
auch die menschheit so programmiert
worden dass sie überlebt und deshalb ist
es auch klar und völlig rational dass
man erst mal versucht in einer notzeit
so sicher wie möglich zu leben
das problem ist aber wir können
natürlich sie haben eingangs gesagt
jetzt hoffen dass der impfstoff die
versprochene verhießen also das ist ja
fast so etwas wie einen auf erden
gekommene heiland also dass der uns
jetzt gewissermaßen erlöst unsere angst
von uns nimmt und uns unser leben zurück
gibt aber die frage ist wenn das nicht
so richtig klappt was machen wir dann
wollen wir dann und ich finde das ist
ein
duncan experiment was man schon einmal
durchspielen muss und darf und dann
kenne ich keinen defekt ist oder was
auch immer wird wenn man sagt wollen wir
tatsächlich wenn das mit dem impfstoff
alles nicht so richtig klappt weil zum
beispiel die herdenimmunität sich
darüber eben doch nicht herstellt wollen
wir dann sagen na gut dann machen wir
das halt noch drei jahre weiter so geht
ihnen aber wollen wir damit riskieren
das ist etwas was man in schweden als
sogenanntes schwedisches modell
ausprobiert hat da hat man gesagt das
ist eine solidarische gesellschaft die
ist ja tatsächlich sehr viel stärker auf
solidarität ausgerichtet auch von der
mentalität her
das hat am anfang ganz gut ausgesehen
dass man im café und im restaurant und
man saß draußen am strand das hat aber
nicht funktioniert weil die todesfälle
viel höher waren als in vergleichbaren
ländern
und wir haben jetzt sogar massive
einschränkungen der freiheit in schweden
also offenbar trotz dieser solidarität
hat es nicht funktioniert
wo ist denn jetzt die grenze wenn ich
sagte schon gesagt der kompromiss ist im
grunde für das virus prima naja was
heißt kompromiss also wenn sie so wollen
wir mehr spitzen das doch mal auf das
eigentliche problem zu
das was gut ist zum maximalen eindämmung
des virus ist für eine offene demokratie
für eine freiheitliche gift und deshalb
setzen wir eigentlich machen
deshalb tun sich auch länder wie china
viel viel leichter natürlich mit der
bekämpfung eines virus weil ein
chinesischer staat operiert sowie so
autoritär
da wird nicht gefragt was der einzelne
will und da wird schon gleich gar nicht
so was wie menschliche spontanität
gefeiert oder groß gehalten im gegenteil
das ist ein störfaktor
und so gesehen ist natürlich ein virus
eine viel schlimmere angriff auf
freiheitliche offene gesellschaften als
es ein angriff auf totalitäre
gesellschaften ist wie zum beispiel die
chinesen aber man hätte doch mal ein
halbes jahr totalitär sein können oder
das haben sie jetzt sie wollen wirklich
sagen mein halbes jahr totalitäres leute
die gesagt haben schaut euch das an wie
das in china gemacht wird macht das
meine kurze zeit und dann habt ihr das
problem nicht
eine diktatur auf abruf münster lesen
wenn ich wirklich etwas überrascht also
ich sage ja aber also wenn wir es ernst
meinen mit unserem bekenntnis unserem
wunderbaren grundgesetz was in
deutschland nun wirklich mühsam genug
errungen wurde also gerade in
deutschland in einem land was zweimal
verbrecherische erfahrung mit
totalitären systemen gemacht hat es gab
vor einigen wochen einen artikel von
einem schriftsteller kollegen thomas
brussig der in der ehemaligen ddr
geboren ist er auch den für mich
unsäglichen pickel mehr diktatur wagen
über seinem text aber sage leute habt
ihr nichts gelernt aus einer geschichte
also man kann doch nicht eben mal mit
ein bisschen diktatur liebäugeln um zu
sagen na ja die die schaffen wir dann
schon wieder ab wir kehren dann schon
wieder
freiheit ist ein kostbares gut und ein
verletzliches gut nicht nur menschliche
lebens und verletzlich wir haben über
datenschutz diskutiert in einer phase wo
menschen starben muss man dann noch über
datenschutz diskutieren
wir haben in einer phase über
datenschutz diskutiert menschen sterben
jeden tag ich weiß dass so ein satz den
man öffentlich im augenblick eigentlich
nicht sagen darf weil dann gebrüllt wird
ja wir nehmen die über toten in kauf
aber zunächst einmal muss man doch sagen
das ist schon ein mögliches problem in
der unsere sicht auf die pandemie ist
dass wir jetzt immer nur auf die korona
totenzahlen schauen
aus meiner sicht ich hätte mir gewünscht
dass medien zb mal sagen wir berichten
mal eine woche lang über alle toten
wir berichten nicht nur über die toten
die an oder mit kobe 19 gestorben sind
jeder einzelne tod ist in einer
freiheitlichen gesellschaft eine
tragödie
daran glaube ich sehr wohl aber es gibt
ja auch noch die vielen vielen anderen
toten wissen sie spontan wie viele
menschen ohnehin jenseits von pandemie
zeiten in deutschland täglich sterben
die zahl habe ich nicht sehen sind wir
schauen nur auf die eine zahl ich kann
sie ihnen sagen
in ganz normalen zeiten sterben jeden
tag in deutschland zweieinhalb tausend
menschen jeden tag völlig normal
auf diese zahl gucken wie nicht wir
fixieren uns auf diese zahl und denken
oh gott sonst sterben ja menschen nicht
und plötzlich sterben ganz wie damit wir
können
die anderen toten ja verhindern das ist
ja der unterschied dass menschen an
krankheiten an altersgebrechen sterben
ist ja völlig normal
wir müssen jetzt ohnehin über das thema
tod sprechen aber wir akzeptieren dann
plötzlich oder sollen akzeptieren dass
es mehr sind und dass dabei auch
menschen sind denen man noch ein langes
leben hätte gönnen können und die auch
noch eins gehabt hätten das kann ich
nicht nachvollziehen
sie haben ja sie haben ja in ihrem buch
trost beschrieben eine situation die sie
ein bisschen verklausuliert haben weil
sie etwas ähnliches erlebt haben von
johanna johanna verliert ihre mutter und
diese mutter ist mit viel mut noch
einmal nach italien gefahren obwohl das
ganz unklug war und stirbt und sie
beschreiben wie sehr sich johanna
darüber aufregt was für eine wut im
bauch sie hat wie verzweifelt sie ist
sie haben 2008 selber ihre mutter
verloren und sie haben gesagt ich bin
beim tod dabei gewesen
ja ein ganz anderes verhältnis
wahrscheinlich zum tod gewonnen
wie haben sie das in dem roman
verarbeitet
ich glaube jetzt nicht der sich
unmittelbar den das sterben meiner
mutter in diesem roman verarbeitet habe
ich beschäftige mich seit dieser zeit
seit 13 jahren habe ich persönlich ein
ganz anderes verhältnis zu der tatsache
meiner eigenen endlichkeit
die ist mir schon lange bewusst ich weiß
gar nicht wann wahrscheinlich als meine
großmutter starb als ich acht war oder
mein großvater als ich acht war aber es
wirklich spüren dass dieses leben ein
ende hat das ist was neues und das ist
mir in der tat erst seit 2008 bewusst
geworden und seither treibt mich diese
frage um was macht das mit unserem leben
was macht das mit unseren gesellschaften
wenn wir mit dem tod eigentlich nur in
einer weise umgehen wir verdrängen
wir wollen diesen tod nicht wahrhaben es
gab zeiten auch in unserer gesellschaft
in anderen gesellschaften ist es zum
teil noch so da gibt es so was wie eine
ars moriendi kunst des sterbens das ist
das bewusstsein dass wir menschen alle
zum tod hin leben zur sterblichkeit
verdammt sind
und da stellt sich die frage ist es klug
bei irgend etwas was uns alle
miteinander vereinen wird ist es da
wirklich klug dem nur verdrängen zu
begegnen und zu sagen wir müssen unser
handeln danach ausrichten dass maximal
wegzudrängen oder muss man versuchen und
ich kann ihnen da auch keine patent
antwort geben das ist die die frage des
menschseins wie man seinen frieden mit
diesem jahr skandal dass jeder einzelne
von uns gehen muss wie kann ich mit
diesem skandal meinen frieden machen
ohne jetzt einen krassen fatalismus zu
verfallen und zu sagen na ja dann soll
der herr mein leben halt morgen nehmen
geschlecht ist vorbei und ohne aber
dieses das leben nur noch dem imperativ
unterzuordnen wirklich alles zu
unterlassen was das leben gefährden
könnte weil wenn wir das ganz ernst
nehmen dann darf ich eigentlich schon
gar nicht mehr vor die tür gehen weil
mich kann ein auto überfahren das
baugerüst vom nachbarn zusammenstürzen
und mir auf den kopf fallen ich kann mir
eine fürchterliche
lebensmittelvergiftung zu ziehen ich bin
um zählt von morgens bis abends von
gefahren und wenn ich mir ständig klar
machen von welchen gefahren ich umziehe
ich bin bleibt irgendwann vom leben
einfach nur so viel übrig sie haben das
in diesem schönen satz geäußert das
leben lässt sich umarmen wenn wir bereit
sind den tod zusammen
das ist die hoffnung diese romanfigur
johanna hofft dass sie selber dahin
kommt in die ist tief ambivalent die ist
zerrissen in diesem gefühl sie findet
den tod auch einen riesigen skandal
gefährt große geister der vergangenheit
auf susan sontag sie im grunde büro
alias canetti alles menschen die sich
als todfeinde bezeichnet die sagen
dieser tod ist ein skandal um gehört
eigentlich abgeschafft und gleichzeitig
weiß sie na ja es ist so ich muss
irgendwie gucken kann ich meinen frieden
damit machen und das ist glaube ich die
große große lebenskunst zu sagen weder
eben fatalistisch sich hinzusetzen wie
es in manchen kulturkreisen ja auch
heute noch der fall ist und sagt da gibt
es eine durchgängige gott ergebenheit
schicksalsergebenheit zu sagen es liegt
alles nicht in meiner hand und dann gibt
es diese kontrollwahn kulturen und wir
tendieren deutlich zu der dieser
wir haben alles im griff wir müssen
alles im griff behalten
loos dem schicksal keinen fußbreit in
die tür lassen und für mich besteht
lebenskunst darin und dann letzten endes
wahrscheinlich auch die politische kunst
in klugen weg zu finden
dieses zwischen beiden abzuwägen ich
glaube nicht dass man eine einfache
harmonie hinkriegt im sinne von
kompromiss sondern dass es immer gilt
sich dieser beiden pole ja das ist der
stolz der menschlichen zivilisation des
menschlichen fortschritts dass wir uns
vom schicksal möglichst wenig bieten
lassen
die menschheit sucht permanent nach
strategie und am besten ist das dann
immer wenn man mit dem tod direkt
verhandelt war ein etwas verlängertes
leben was es ja in der literatur auch
sehr gerne gibt sie haben geschrieben
wir brauchen einen aufstand der
schönheits suchenden würde süchtigen
lebens verliebten einen aufstand gegen
die technokratie das was wir jetzt
gerade erleben ist ja technokratie das
ist ja im grunde genommen die hoffnung
darauf dass die wissenschaft uns aus
diesem dilemma jetzt mal erst erlöst und
im zweifelsfall ja auch ihr es gelingt
tote zu vermeiden ist das nicht gerade
der gegensatz den wir jetzt erleben naja
die wissenschaft kann uns und ich bin
ein unbedingter fan also ich sehr
wahrscheinlich da nicht bei ihnen hier
in diesem sessel wenn es keine
avancierte medizin gebe weil ich musste
sofort im brutkasten nach der geburt das
reicht noch nicht ganz aber passierte
aber immerhin doch auch schon also vor
100 jahren hätte ich wahrscheinlich
keine große chancen gehabt meine ersten
tage oder wochen zu überleben in eine
unbedingte anhängerin von avancierter
medizin und trotzdem bleibt das thema
nehme ich halt und trost her wenn all
diese systeme eben irgendwann doch
versagen so wie es zumindest in den
ersten monaten einer pandemie
klarerweise der fall war
wir wussten noch fast nicht über
therapie möglichkeiten wir hatten noch
gar keinen impfstoff da saßen wir alle
völlig verängstigt auf unserer
endlichkeit zurückgeworfen
da und jetzt kann man natürlich sagen
wir und ich bin und keine
missverständnisse erzeugen ich bin
unbedingt dafür ich bewundere jeden
wissenschaftler der an dieser front
forscht weil wie gesagt das macht
den menschlichen fortschritt und
letztlich auch einen menschlichen stolz
aus dass er sich eben gegen schicksal
auflehnt und trotzdem und das ist die
tiefe erfahrung die ich vor 13 jahren am
eigenen leib gemacht es kommt der moment
wo wir alle da stehen und jegliche
technik am ende ist mit ihrem witz und
natürlich kann man sagen darüber will
ich jetzt nicht nachdenken das halte ich
mir mal lieber vom leib das ist mir zu
unangenehm
ich halte das nicht für klug ich halte
es für klug sich klarzumachen wir alle
werden sei es unser eigenes leben aber
zunächst einmal auch das leben von
liebsten von eltern von anderen
verwandten wir alle werden mit dem
moment konfrontiert werden wo auch der
beste arzt der welt sagen wird ich kann
nichts mehr machen und auf diesem moment
muss man glaube ich innerlich gefasst
sein und die große frage ist was haben
wir noch an kultur praktiken wenn wir
keinen religiösen trost und den haben
nicht mehr sehr sehr viele einige
menschen haben denn sie haben ja gesagt
sie sind agnostiker rinn
man kann ja drei perspektiven auf machen
man kann das sozusagen in blick nehmen
was wir im augenblick haben die todes
vermeidung also nicht nur rational sich
möglichst wenig damit
auseinanderzusetzen immer auf die
wissenschaftler hoffen die wird uns das
noch verlängern noch mal verlängern
manche glauben ja auch irgendwann wäre
es so weit dass wir so lange leben wie
wir wollen dann kann man so vorgehen wie
sieht es tun und sagen wir müssen uns
damit beschäftigen weil wir wissen ja
nicht was danach kommt es ist ja schön
eigentlich im mittelalter gelebt zu
haben wo man sagt er ja da kommt ja noch
nass also dieses leben ist ja nur
sozusagen das vorleben die johanna
streitet genau in diesen bereichen
sozusagen mit sich selber auch sehr
emotional mit sich selber sehr
menschlich mit mit sich selber aber in
der phase in der wir jetzt sind wie
sollen wir uns da jetzt orientieren
naja es ist eine phrase sie selber haben
sie auch mehrfach betont ist wird
gestorben und vor allem wir gucken
ständig auf den tod drauf und deshalb
ist es glaube ich ein guter moment mit
sich selber mit seinen liebsten mit
anderen darüber zu reden
lasst uns über dieses hässliche thema
über das wir nicht reden wollen ganz
konkret auch
eben eltern mit geschwistern zu sagen
hast du dir jemand gedanken darüber
gemacht zum beispiel wie viel medizin
willst du noch in dein lebensende
reinlassen
das einzige memento mori was wir heute
ja noch quasi kenntnis so was wie eine
patientenverfügung was ja auch eine form
ist sich gedanken zu machen über die
frage wie will ich aus meinem leben
gehen oder das ist auch eine möglichkeit
die johanna in dem buch immerhin in
erwägung zieht wir müssen das irgendwie
schaffen so stoische haltung zu finden
der wahnsinnig eleganten formulierung zu
sagen also lange ich da drin ist der tod
nicht da und wenn der tod da ist bin ich
nicht mehr da also gekauft der
aromatische geht nicht der tod nichts an
ich finde es einen unglaublich eleganten
philosophischen gedanken ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob er wirklich funktioniert
und wo finden wir halt wo finden wir
trost und mir immer klarer geworden dass
der trost wenn man dann eben nicht daran
glaubt dass man in gottes hand ist und
gott ein held trost hat ganz massiv was
mit dem gefühl des gehalten science zu
tun
und das hat direkt auch was mit
menschlicher nähe zu tun und deshalb ist
natürlich dieses ganze system sync sie
haben völlig recht was wir
vernünftigerweise praktizieren und auch
ich vernünftigerweise praktiziere
und trotzdem ist das ein gewaltiger
motor der trostlosigkeit und trostloser
wir werden weil alles das was uns so
halt gibt desto verzweifelter klammern
wir uns eben oder in eine wissenschaft
zu sagen also erlöse uns anstatt auch zu
überlegen was haben wir an seelischen
widerstands kräften wie können wir uns
innerlich wappnen um solche schweren
furchtbaren zeiten so durchzustehen dass
wir eben nicht verzweifeln und nicht
verrückt werden
deswegen finde ich das auch sehr
interessant dass sie gesagt haben also
ich finde entspannung trost nehme ich
jetzt mal zusammen eigentlich weniger
bei der literatur da muss ich mich
richtig mit ihm auseinandersetzen
intellektuell sondern bei der musik dann
haben sie schubert zum beispiel
angesprochen auch dass sich in der natur
bewegen es sie was ganz wichtig ist hier
angesagt
durch den wald gehen das ist etwas wo
ich entspannung finde und nicht nur
entspannung im sinne von blutdruck
senken sondern auch entspannung im sinne
von da fühle ich mich wohler fühlen
ich mich geborgen da steht uns ja die
nächste katastrophe ins haus und das
muss man ja auch so sagen wenn wir sie
werden oft genug im wald sehen was da
los ist wenn wir daran denken dass ich
da eine entwicklung vollzieht die uns
nicht ein zwei oder drei jahre begleitet
sondern schon lange begleitet und
möglicherweise auch sehr übel enden wird
für die menschheit wie sehen sie denn
dem entgegen wenn sie sagen man muss
sich jetzt nicht ständig nur mit
katastrophen auseinandersetzen
ich glaube dass man sich mit dem was ich
an unheil zusammen braucht an einem
horizont und man allen grund anzunehmen
dass ich das schlimme dinge
zusammenbrauen
damit muss man sich unbedingt
beschäftigen ich bin kein vogel strauß
und ich finde nicht dass man köpfe in
irgendwelchen sand stecken soll
und trotzdem wiederhole ich ist ich
glaube eine einseitige fixierung auf
worst case szenarios bringt menschen um
den verstand und deshalb man muss worst
case kennen und muss die mal
durchgespielt haben aber das hat
natürlich da müssten wir auch noch über
medien und mediale aufbereitung von
solchen themen reden jetzt sind wir
wieder
naja ich dazu ich bin ja auch teil der
medien so gesehen können wir dann gerne
sagen ja sind wir dieses ständige
fixieren auf im einen worst case dass
das macht das ist irgendwann nicht mehr
erlebbar und das heißt nicht dass man
weg guckt also eine gewisse form aber
einer gelassenheit der religiöse mensch
würde vielleicht sogar seine zuversicht
glaube ja wir müssen erst case szenarien
studieren und gleichzeitig brauchen wir
zuversicht wenn wir die nicht mehr haben
das halte ich dann auch wirklich für
politisch ganz ganz gefährlich wir sind
offen für jeden rattenfänger der uns
rettung und erlösung verspricht ich
glaube für einen immunsystem von
demokratien um diesen einen augenblick
griff ist sozusagen in der virologischen
front auch ständig hören um den mann auf
demokratien zu übertragen ich glaube
eine demokratie braucht für immunsystem
zuversicht dass es gut werden kann wenn
man nur noch davon überzeugt ist ist es
furchtbar
dann sind wir wieder bei dem punkt wo
wir eben einen heftigeren dissenz hatten
dann muss man sagen demokratie ist nicht
mehr geeignet um in katastrophalen
zuständen was auszurichten also her mit
der diktatur
und da wird mir ich wiederhole es in
einer weise mulmig dass ich sage ihnen
dieses worst case szenario möchte ich
mich nicht wir gucken ja aber am
wochenende viele george orwell noch mal
gelesen ein buch was mir sehr sehr unter
die haut gegangen ist gerade jetzt als
wieder lektüre in diesen zeiten also
wenn die menschheit glaubt dass der
einzige weg wie sie sich retten kann ist
dass sie insgesamt sagt wir tendieren
zum totalitären dann weiß ich nicht ob
ich diese menschheit noch so lieben kann
wie ich sie im augenblick vor
begeisterung für theodor w adorno haben
sie den namen der gewählt das ist ja nun
ein richtiger denker gewesen und das ist
ja keine frage das ist ja keine frage
dass uns das denken voranbringt aber das
was sie auch in der gestalt der
romanheldin deutlich machen ist viel
viel emotionen wie viel emotion ist bei
ihnen und wie viel ration naja ich hoffe
doch beides aber in welchem verhältnis
also soll ich jetzt prozent zusammen wir
leben gerade unter den sieben der zahl
naja ich hab philosophie studiert hat
philosophie unterrichtet und habe es
dann nicht mehr getan weil ich eben auch
irgendwann merkte dass ich glaube wenn
man nur rational auf die probleme guckt
das ist nur die halbe wahrheit
der mensch besteht genauso aus emotionen
und die frage ist doch eher wie gelingt
es einem dem vernünftigen anteil mit dem
möglicherweise irrationalen weil die
gefühle mit ihm durchgehen anteil
das macht auch menschsein aus wie kriege
ich beides zusammen und deshalb habe ich
auch eben sehr früh gewusst ich schreibe
über dieses thema kein nur rationalen
essay sondern ich will aber eine figur
nehmen die ist ja durchaus ziemlich
rational diese johanna die ist ja so ein
bisschen wie sie spielt mit sich selber
spielen ist zu harmlos die die ist wie
ein jojo also mit der gegen die
verzweiflung beule nacht durch ich meine
der es eben wirklich entsetzliches
passiert dann dann tobt die auch mal
nacht und am nächsten morgen setzte sich
hin schreibt den nächsten brief und sagt
ja weil es schon ich war ungerecht es
mit mir durchgegangen und ist das nicht
eigentlich das sympathischste was wir
als menschen können also ich will doch
den menschen seinen zorn und seine
fraktion nicht ab erzielen
das muss diese gefühle müssen ihren raum
kriegen und der raum für diese gefühle
ist um himmels willen nicht der
öffentliche raum im sinne von gut
demonstration auf plätzen bin ich die
erste die sagt es ist unheil in der luft
wenn der sogenannte wutbürger den
öffentlichen raum erobert aber diese
gefühle müssen den eindruck haben sie
dürfen irgendwo mal raus und sich dann
aber wieder eben besinnen zu können und
sagen zu können ja mit mir sind wut
goldene durch gedanken ich war ungerecht
und ich habe letzte nacht unsinn geredet
sich gewissermaßen auch entschuldigen
können dafür das macht doch menschsein
aus oder werden wir jetzt wieder ein
szenario werden wir nachdem wir von der
wissenschaft möglicherweise gerettet
worden sind
das sieht ja zumindest im augenblick so
aus zu einer neuen wissenschafts
gläubigkeit kommen und dazu wieder zu
wenig mensch und sehr viel wissenschaft
und ratio nach der panne ist nicht ich
bin relativ prognose müde deshalb möchte
ich jetzt ungern prognosen abgeben wie
es mit der wissenschaft weiter geht ich
kann ihnen nur sagen es gibt einen trend
in unserem umgang mit der wissenschaft
dem ich eher nachdenklich besorgen voll
stimmt und das ist der umgang dieses
schlagwort von owens folgt der
wissenschaftler wissenschaft gibt es nur
im plural in dem einen sinne das ist
sich hunderte mittlerweile disziplin von
wissenschaft gibt und man kann nicht
immer nur sagen ich höre bei einem
problem immer nur auf die eine also
jetzt im augenblick auf die virologen
epidemiologen ich halte das tatsächlich
für ein großes problem dass wir viel zu
einseitig nur jetzt sagen die sind jetzt
die wissenschaft und außerdem ist es ja
nun auch so also wir haben ja hier auch
prominente vertreter im eigenen land
nehmen sie klaus stöhr von der whu
durchaus als wissenschaftler einige
dinge sehr anders sieht als das was im
augenblick die offizielle richtung ist
der wissenschaftler auf die politik hört
deshalb und das ist wissenschaft
wissenschaft ist rationaler streit um
die beste lösung und aus wissenschaft
gewissermaßen die geeinte kirche zu
machen und zu sagen da ist die wahrheit
und auf diese wahrheit hören wir das ist
leider unwissenschaftlich das entspricht
einem tiefen menschlichen und da sind
wir ein haltloser mensch der sich nach
orientierung sehen der will dass da der
eine
die eine steht und ihm ganz klar sagt
dies ist die wahrheit und daran zweifelt
du nicht aber das ist nicht wissenschaft
das ist keine wissenschaftliche haltung
wissenschaftliche haltung geht davon aus
dass man in der auseinandersetzung in
der rationalen auseinandersetzung die
gerne mit leidenschaft geführt werden
darf aber in der rationalen
auseinandersetzung argumente austauschen
dem gegner zuhört und gemeinsam versucht
schlauer zu werden als man es vorher war
aber nicht zu sagen hier werden dokument
errichtet und jeder der an dieses dogma
nicht glaubt ist dann irgendwie
plötzlich ein wissenschafts find das
halte ich für tatsächlich ein
gefährlichen weg
ganz herzlichen dank für ihren so gern
[Musik]